[MUSIC PLAYING]
BEN ORLIN: Thanks, Max.
And thanks,
everybody, for coming.
I'm really excited to be here.
This is fun.
I've gotten to do--
since the book came
out in September,
I've got to do a few different
events, a lot of them
at colleges, but this is
my first corporate event.
And it's nice, because Google
is basically a big college.
So I appreciate being here.
MAX BLUM-CAMPO: I mean,
note the chairs too, right?
BEN ORLIN: Yeah, that's right.
Yeah.
Yeah, well, this
makes it seem like I'm
a film director, like we're
here to discuss our latest film.
Which maybe we could
try to do that after.
I'll just start by showing a few
images from-- it so I started,
I've been a teacher since
I graduated college.
I started a blog
about five years ago.
I wanted to do--
wanted to write about math,
knew that math needed visuals.
I also knew that I can't draw.
It's just not in my skill set.
So figured I would
disclaim it upfront.
It's gonna be math
with bad drawings.
So I figure I'll just
show a few images
from my writing and my rather
unlikely illustrating career
so far.
So this was right
after, I think,
the month I started the blog.
And this is still probably
one of the, I dunno,
better known, the
more popular pieces
of writing that I've done.
And you can see that my
illustration style is still
developing.
That's me, and I'm
pretty sure I'm supposed
to be pulling out hair.
That's tufts of
hair in my hands,
which was just a grotesque
idea for a drawing among also
not being the best
piece of execution.
MAX BLUM-CAMPO: I
think I didn't quite
understand that the first time
that I looked at it, that that
was what he was holding there.
BEN ORLIN: Yeah, I
think you're not alone.
He just looks like there
are horns or something,
I don't know.
I also learned pretty
soon that I hands are just
a losing battle.
You don't wanna
try to draw hands.
Anyway, but so this essay
is one of the first things
I did on the blog.
And one of the
things I was really
interested in, especially
right when I started writing
about mathematics, moving
from having taught it
for four years at that point
to trying to reach a larger
audience, was mathphobia
and math anxiety,
and this whole suite of
almost psychiatric problems
that people have when
they think about math.
And so this actually, I mean,
like most of my writing,
it's a very kind of
breezy, silly piece
with some jokes in it.
It was incredibly hard to write.
It's an essay about a math class
I took senior year of college
that I struggled in.
And when I sat down
to write it there,
I was about 500 or
thousand words deep,
and it was all disclaimers of
like, "well just so you know,
I'm actually pretty
good at this stuff.
So it's not that I'm bad at it."
And the idea of actually
looking directly
at where I had
struggled and where
I had failed in this class, it
was like looking at the sun.
It was really hard to just
bring my focus towards that.
And in some sense,
most of the writing
I've done since then
flows out of that,
I think trying to look at the
experience, which is really not
fun to look at, but of
being in a math class,
running into something
that you don't understand,
and just kind of
feeling like an idiot.
Which is something, if you take
enough math, you wind up there.
I mean, everybody
has that experience
at one point or another.
Anyway, and so that was,
from the start, something
that I was thinking
about with the blog.
Another piece, this was a year
or two later, a similar angle.
And you can see my
drawing style evolving.
Basically, not
trying to do as much.
No noses, no hands.
This was in the midst of what
I call my Long Neck Phase,
where all my stick figures had
necks that were much too long.
And also, I think,
understanding what,
as someone who has no
background in drawing
and really no comfort
with it as a medium
or as a skill, what
can I do is basically
try to come up with
some concepts for images
and have the concept override
my lack of technique.
So this was one where I
think a common kind of meme
in the culture
around mathematics
is that you hit
some maximum point.
For some people, it's algebra 1.
For some people, it's their
trigonometry or calculus class
in high school.
For some people, they
take abstract algebra,
and they start learning
about rings and fields,
and that's where they sort
of fall off the wagon.
And there's this
notion that yeah,
there's a ceiling
that you can advance.
Math is hierarchical.
You climb the ladder.
Then you get to a rung,
and it's like, oh,
you can't go past that
one, because your lungs
don't work that high.
Which I think is wrong.
I don't think
that's how it works,
but it's a very authentic
experience that people have.
So I show this as just
as an example of the kind
of the kind of cartooning I do.
My metaphor is this futon.
It was freshman year of college.
And you may remember
this, actually.
The guys on the
first floor in our--
yeah, we had the
same entryway, yeah.
The guys on the
first floor wanted
to get rid of their futon.
So they're very
nicely carried it up
to the fourth floor for us.
And along the way, like
a little piece broke off.
And we were like, ah,
it's a little piece of it.
It was like a little
piece of metal.
It seemed fine.
And then, like a week later,
the futon was doing that.
And then two weeks later,
it was sort of like that,
dumping in the middle.
And then eventually, it
took like a month or two,
and then the futon was broken.
And I think that to me isn't
a bad metaphor for what
happens in math
education, where there's
a little piece that's missing.
I've taught eighth grade, so
an algebra 1 student can graph
some lines, maybe doesn't
really get what that's about,
doesn't get the idea of
sort of the correspondence
between this equation and the
points on the line or xy pairs
that satisfy the equation.
There's just some
missing understanding,
and it seems fine
in eighth grade,
because they can answer
all the questions.
But as you build further,
the futon kind of
starts to warp, and then at
some point, there's a collapse.
I think that's what
people experience
as a ceiling in math education.
It's not actually them hitting
some kind of cognitive limit
of what they can understand.
It's sort of old fractures
finally leading to a rupture.
Some other more recent drawings.
This one was a fun piece too.
This actually wound
up in the book too.
Partly, I show this--
this is from 2015.
It really doesn't make
sense after 2016, I think.
Because in 2015, it fell
like a credible critique
of political journalists,
that they're always
trying to hype up the
unlikely possibilities.
And then with the 2016 election
surprising a lot of people,
this is one that I had
to change for the book,
because I wanted to--
first, I wanted to make fun
of political journalists,
but this was no longer
the right joke for that.
[CHUCKLING]
MAX BLUM-CAMPO: Is
there an updated version
later in the slides?
BEN ORLIN: Actually, I
don't have it in the slides.
This is the teaser for the book.
MAX BLUM-CAMPO: Oh, nice.
BEN ORLIN: I gotta
go obtain the book.
And this is another one
that winds up in the book,
why not to trust statistics.
This one, you can see
I'm very, very much
in my Long Neck Phase.
MAX BLUM-CAMPO: Very long, wow.
BEN ORLIN: It's really
disproportionate.
MAX BLUM-CAMPO: Wait, can
I pause you for a second?
BEN ORLIN: Yeah, yeah, please.
MAX BLUM-CAMPO: Are you
drawing these on whiteboards?
BEN ORLIN: No, actually.
So originally, yeah.
So back at the very beginning,
I spent a year drawing
on whiteboards.
I thought was a really good
idea to photograph the pens.
I don't know.
People would ask me something
like, "why do you do that?"
I'm like, "That's the
key to the whole thing."
And really, I
don't think it was.
A year later, I
stopped doing it,
and I've never got an email
from someone being like,
"where are the whiteboards?
I miss those."
So then, yeah.
At this point, I
was actually using--
I mean, this is still what I do.
It's just Sharpie on
paper and I scan it.
MAX BLUM-CAMPO: OK,
so I was wondering
how you got that faded area
from a whiteboard marker.
I don't think I would
know how to do that.
BEN ORLIN: Sure,
colored pencils.
MAX BLUM-CAMPO: I didn't
realize you didn't.
BEN ORLIN: Yeah.
Yeah, very, very high tech.
It's Sharpies and
Crayola colored pencils.
MAX BLUM-CAMPO:
Oh, that's great.
BEN ORLIN: So this one was--
right, this is now three
years into the blog.
And I think I was
moving towards--
I wanted to do simpler drawings,
because they are easier,
and also it looks-- if
you do it like this,
it looks like maybe I could
actually draw real things,
and it's just I'm choosing to do
something kind of deliberately
minimalist and simplistic.
Which is a lot.
That's not true.
I can't.
I really can't draw
any more complex.
But if you do it, if you have
the right kind of simple style,
you can almost pull it off.
I was moving towards--
I guess I had started--
I had agents by
this point, and I
was starting to
think about the book,
although I hadn't
I hadn't gotten
in contact with my editor
yet, so the book project
hadn't come together.
But this was this
sort of thing I
knew I wanted to maybe
build a book around.
It's just jokes that
explain simple math ideas.
So this one you can
sort of imagine.
You guys know how means work.
So a mean is very
sensitive to the--
mean is the total divided by
the number of things there are.
It's not sensitive
to distribution,
so this is a plausible--
[LAUGHTER]
I can't.
I really can't look
at these drawings
anymore, because the
necks are so long
and the legs are so short.
Anyway, well, the faces
of always been my focus.
MAX BLUM-CAMPO: This
is really upsetting.
BEN ORLIN: And then this
one wound up floating
around Twitter, but
it was sort of--
[LAUGHTER]
That's probably the
best joke I've written.
That feels like a joke I
discovered rather than writing.
It's a very simple joke
that was there already.
And it was doing
really well on Twitter,
but I hadn't tweeted it out.
Someone else had tweeted it out
without attributing it to me.
So the dangers of social media.
Mostly, I'm just trying to
claim my credit belatedly.
MAX BLUM-CAMPO:
This may have been
in the essay that went along
with this particular cartoon,
but I don't remember.
Is the claim here
that there was--
you're explaining why
there was one time that
was both the best and
the worst of times?
BEN ORLIN: I guess, yeah.
I mean, it was my best joke.
I can't say I've read
"Tale of Two Cities."
MAX BLUM-CAMPO: OK.
BEN ORLIN: It's a beautiful--
I've read the opening paragraph.
It's a lovely opening paragraph.
I assume because it's
two cities in the title.
I assume one of them, it's
real good, and one of them,
it's real bad there?
MAX BLUM-CAMPO: Yeah.
BEN ORLIN: But don't ask
me what the two cities are.
Paris has gotta be one.
Anyway, and then this
is a more recent essay.
So this point is five years in.
I guess if you'd
asked me 2013 if I
was gonna have five or
more years of things to say
about mathematics, doing
a post or two a week,
and lately I've been doing
four cartoons a week,
I think I might not have been
too optimistic about continuing
to have fresh ideas.
But to some extent,
I mean, this is
what I think what
writing almost anything
is, is finding fresh ways
to present or to discuss
old insights.
So one of my favorite
essays I've written,
which isn't in the book but
may appear in a feature book,
was I actually got the chance
to ask a question of Andrew
Wiles, who was the
mathematician who
proved Fermat's last
theorem after this 350-year
to try to figure out
what this lost proof was,
which clearly
Fermat did not have.
And so I got to ask Wile
in a way that research
mathematicians don't, usually.
He gets a chance to speak
to a much wider audience.
He's sort of a figure in
the popular imagination,
and what's the message
that he tries to send
when he gets those chances?
And what he said was
basically that mathematics
is about being stuck and being
comfortable with being stuck.
And that to solve problems
is to kind of glory
in that phase, where
you've entered,
you see what the problem is,
you see what the destination is
you're trying to get to.
You just don't know
how to get there,
and to grow
comfortable with that
and to grow to
enjoy that process.
And he said it
really beautifully,
so I just did some cartoons and
a little bit of my own prose
elaborating on that.
But that's still, in any given
week, probably one of the more
visited posts on my
blog, because it's
sort of a timeless message.
I mean, which makes
sense for a guy
who spent a decade solving
a 350-year-old problem.
He's good at coming up with
fairly timeless wisdom.
And then, yeah, so
this leads to the--
MAX BLUM-CAMPO: It's a
pretty universal idea too.
BEN ORLIN: Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, it stretches
beyond math, I think.
MAX BLUM-CAMPO: Yeah.
BEN ORLIN: This is my
wife's favorite joke.
She's a research mathematician.
And it's not the absolute
best joke, but you know,
it makes her happy.
I've been doing more
cartoons lately,
trying to-- you can
see my illustration,
you can see it's getting better.
Those necks are much
more proportionate .
To the oven almost has a
plausible geometry to it.
So I'm proud.
MAX BLUM-CAMPO: I'm very
impressed with the oven.
BEN ORLIN: Thank you.
Yeah, let's go back to the oven.
MAX BLUM-CAMPO: Yeah, the
glass on the front door, well,
the only door of the oven--
BEN ORLIN: Thank you.
MAX BLUM-CAMPO: Yeah.
BEN ORLIN: Thank you, Max.
MAX BLUM-CAMPO: You're welcome.
BEN ORLIN: That's exactly right.
I'll tell you, that's
an afternoon right
to make that happen.
[LAUGHTER]
And then actually, recently,
so my first book came out
in September, and
I've got another one
with the same
publisher coming out.
We don't have the
publication day yet,
but probably this fall.
And so that's been
fun working on that.
It's about calculus.
So you know, the
mathematics of change.
And the illustrations
are black and white,
which actually I just
thought was kind of classy.
I don't know.
And I liked the
challenge of trying
to-- because usually I rely
on color as kind of a crutch.
It's like like, "look,
it's green and blue.
And don't worry about
how poorly drawn it is."
And so having to do it
with black and white
was fun to work on.
Those are some of the
more recent drawings.
I've got red too.
You can see the bloodshot
eyes of the waiting child.
MAX BLUM-CAMPO: Yeah, no.
The child really seems
to be in distress there.
BEN ORLIN: Yeah.
Yeah, actually, I find myself--
MAX BLUM-CAMPO: Very graphic.
BEN ORLIN: Sometimes when
I'm drawing faces like that,
I'll catch myself kind
of making the face.
This is the level of
amateur artist I am.
I can't actually draw a panicked
person without reminding myself
what panic feels like.
Or maybe that makes
me a great artist?
I don't know.
MAX BLUM-CAMPO: I bet a
lot of us would do that,
if we were drawing
panic like that.
BEN ORLIN: Yeah.
I like to think so.
Anyway, yeah, those are
just some images that
span my whole artistic career.
Which, I think if you
would tell my sisters,
who have always known me as
an utterly incompetent artist,
the first time I had a blog post
that wound up at the Huffington
Post, they'd read it
on their homepage.
And the byline they wrote
for me without asking me
was "writer and artist."
And my sisters both called
me within like 30 seconds.
"What's with artist?
What did you tell them?
What kind of lies
are you peddling
to the Huffington Post?"
MAX BLUM-CAMPO:
And sorry, what you
had written for the
Huffington Post did not
include a drawing at the time?
BEN ORLIN: That was
back in my photographs
of the whiteboard marker phase.
MAX BLUM-CAMPO: Yeah, OK.
BEN ORLIN: It was
those early days.
MAX BLUM-CAMPO: OK, so
they were willing to bestow
that title on you.
BEN ORLIN: Yeah, I think they--
I don't know what they
were reading into it.
"Artist" was clearly a bit
of a lofty title for it.
MAX BLUM-CAMPO: Well,
and the Huffington Post
isn't your sister, so I
guess a little more lenient.
BEN ORLIN: Yeah, that's fair.
MAX BLUM-CAMPO: You've sort
of answered this a little bit,
but if you had to really
focus in, what would
you say was your
inspiration for even just
the blog, Math
with Bad Drawings?
BEN ORLIN: Yeah,
It's interesting.
I think my ambition
has maybe-- actually,
even as the reach of
the blog has grown
and I've gotten to do these
sort of exciting book projects,
I think my ambition has
probably narrowed a bit.
I think at the start--
I started the blog
when I was 24, 25.
Yeah, 25.
So I think at that
time I had this idea
that good writing
about mathematics
could really make it
totally accessible to people
for whom it was inaccessible.
Yeah, it's hard for me to
climb back inside the mindset,
because I think now I tend
to take a little bit more
of a systemic view, and there's
a lot of big challenges in math
education.
And a guy writing
cartoons is not
gonna transform
anything particularly.
The way I think about
it now is, my goal
is to give people positive
experiences of mathematics.
You know, whether
there's someone
who has a professional
relationship to mathematics,
or someone--
I mean, especially
people who don't
have that kind of relationship,
for whom mathematics
was kind of a bane, and was a
difficulty in their schooling
years.
Not that I expect my
drawings and my writing
to suddenly turn
them into Googlers,
but to maybe help them just
have a day of reconciliation
and have a couple
laughs with mathematics,
is how I think about it.
MAX BLUM-CAMPO: Yeah, because
I guess they don't really--
you're not writing
a curriculum, you're
just taking individual
one-off ideas.
BEN ORLIN: Yeah, exactly.
And then there's brilliant
people out there, man.
I know some people who
work on curricular stuff,
and it's really
interesting to me.
MAX BLUM-CAMPO:
Curricular cartoons?
BEN ORLIN: Cartoons?
That would be cool, man.
No, no.
Yeah, I don't know a lot people
doing that, but designing
curriculum, and new Common
Core-aligned curricula.
And that's really cool work,
and yeah, not what I'm doing.
I'm just I'm just making jokes.
MAX BLUM-CAMPO: So you mentioned
challenges in math education,
and you have
significant experience
in that area yourself.
So what do you think are
current and important challenges
in math education?
BEN ORLIN: Yeah, yeah.
I mean, I think
definitely there's--
probably a lot of
people in this room
have interesting
thoughts on this--
but how mathematics is
going to adapt to the fact
that, in the last 20 years,
the technological environment
has completely transformed.
Education tends to be
pretty slow moving, but not
infinitely slow moving.
I think you already
see a bit of a shift
away from some of the
computational emphasis
in the younger grades.
I'd say just middle schoolers,
it's not it's less about--
it was very important
when we were in school,
you had to learn to
divide a five digit
number by a two digit number.
MAX BLUM-CAMPO: Yeah.
BEN ORLIN: And
they don't really.
And honestly, it's not that--
this is a controversial
one, but I
don't think that's a
particularly important skill.
I think being able to execute
the algorithm with a one digit
number, sure.
Being able to estimate is
a really important skill
and probably a harder one than
executing a standard algorithm.
So that's sort of one
general issue, I think,
is how math education will
adapt to the new technological
environment.
MAX BLUM-CAMPO:
And are you saying
that it still is the
case that there's
a big computational emphasis
when you're younger,
and you think that's one
thing that needs to change?
BEN ORLIN: Yeah, yeah.
MAX BLUM-CAMPO: Or do you see
that change happening already?
BEN ORLIN: It's true.
I mean, classrooms
are so diverse that I
think there's still definitely
lots of classrooms where
teachers are teaching in
a pretty traditional way,
and not really
acknowledging the reality
that we've all got a
calculator in our pocket,
and the calculator is
better than any calculator
you could get 20 years ago.
And so there's two
different classrooms
where it's time to
update and acknowledge
that the set of skills
that's important has changed.
But for any classroom
that has one problem,
you can always find a classroom
with an opposite problem.
So I'm always a
little wary of trying
to prescribe general solutions.
MAX BLUM-CAMPO: Prescribe screen
time and skipping the work.
BEN ORLIN: Yeah.
MAX BLUM-CAMPO: But I remember
that in elementary school,
they were always a
lot of people who
were very challenged by exactly
what you're talking about,
by long division and
long multiplication.
BEN ORLIN: Yeah.
MAX BLUM-CAMPO: It
was very frustrating.
On a different tack, what
did your book writing process
like look like for "Math
with Bad Drawings"?
BEN ORLIN: Yeah, yeah.
So the book is in five sections.
The first one is sort of a
very general introduction
to mathematics, and then the
next four each take you--
there's one on probability,
and one on geometry,
and one on statistics.
And so basically, I was
teaching at the time.
So I spent a few months
opening a document,
and looking it over, and
changing three words here
or there, and fussing with it.
So that was always
the way I'd written.
Because before that, people
weren't really paying
me to write, and I just
could do it when I wanted.
And then I did that
for a few months,
and then looked up
and was like, "Oh, I
need to write a chapter
every four days now in order
to finish the book on time."
And what that meant is, I
started writing really fast.
And luckily, that first
section of the book, I
got to fiddle with.
And then the later sections
are much more modular.
I had to, with a lot
help from my editor,
come up with basically spots
in the world, where you've
got useful mathematics
and mathematics that's
really low to the ground.
You don't need a chapter on
expected value or something
like that.
Where you don't need
a lot of background
to access the mathematics.
And then it was sort of,
got a few days per chapter
to kind dive in and
spend a day or two
doing background reading.
Four days, it may have
been more like a week,
I guess, per chapter that I had.
As I fell behind, I had to--
MAX BLUM-CAMPO: That still
sounds pretty overwhelming,
though.
BEN ORLIN: It felt
really fast, yeah.
Yeah, I'm really happy
with how the book came out,
and certainly my publisher
does a really beautiful job
designing the
physical book itself.
MAX BLUM-CAMPO: Mm-hmm.
BEN ORLIN: But
yeah, so the process
was very leisurely
at the beginning,
and then a lot faster.
MAX BLUM-CAMPO: And who's
the publisher again?
BEN ORLIN: It's Black
Dog & Leventhal,
they're an imprint of Hachette.
MAX BLUM-CAMPO: How long
did it take in total,
including both the
slow moving part
at the beginning of
the writing process
and finishing the final draft?
BEN ORLIN: Yeah.
Yeah, I guess we probably
got the book deal in October,
and then spent a few
months outlining.
Then again, my editor
was really good.
She pushed back on what I
think is a natural tendency.
My degree is in
pure mathematics,
so I have a certain blithe
confidence that just like,
"Oh yeah, prime numbers
are just interesting
for their own sake."
For some people, they are.
I think in my original outline
I had planned several chapters
on prime numbers and
then kind of hitting
RSA encryption at
the end of that,
in very non-technical terms.
And she was saying
for the sort of book
we're hoping to do,
lots of pure mathematics
with a payoff in
something fairly technical
wasn't really--
we want like lottery tickets.
That's the kind of [INAUDIBLE].
Like, the Death Star
is another chapter.
So I think orienting me back
towards stuff that was--
MAX BLUM-CAMPO: Real
world stuff like that.
BEN ORLIN: Yeah, exactly.
Real world stuff
like the Death Star.
Exactly.
Really just concrete stuff
you run into every day.
Yeah, so it was outlining
at the beginning, yeah,
and bouncing ideas back
and forth with my editor,
and then probably three
months or so mostly
working on that first section
at a fairly inefficient clip,
and then a pretty hasty
five months or so.
I don't think those numbers
add up to the correct amount,
but, don't check.
There's no way of
knowing, really.
MAX BLUM-CAMPO: I don't think
I have a calculator nearby.
BEN ORLIN: That's
exactly it, yeah.
MAX BLUM-CAMPO: Did
you find anything
really surprising about
either the writing process
or the publishing process,
aside from the fact
that a book mostly
about prime numbers
might not be right
for the audience?
BEN ORLIN: I was shocked
to find that that's not
something-- my editor, who's
has edited lots of pop science
books, but her background's
not in mathematics.
So it turned out coming to
her with a proposal that
was 1/3 about prime numbers
wasn't striking her fancy.
Yeah, well, actually, I
just finished the manuscript
for the second book with
the same publisher now.
I think both books have
really surprised me.
I mean, it's just a
scale of writing project
that I hadn't done before.
"Math with Bad Drawings"
actually pleasantly
surprised me,
because I was really
excited to get the
opportunity to write the book.
I was like a little pessimistic
or a little skeptical
that I could write a
book I'd be satisfied
with that was about math.
That struck me as
too broad a topic.
Like, you wouldn't
hire a history teacher
to write a book about history.
Just give us the
greatest hits of history,
just an overview of history.
It's like too much?
Or like, science?
You wouldn't be like, "Oh,
yeah, like science teacher, just
use science.
Just cover it."
MAX BLUM-CAMPO:
Isn't that like how
most of the textbooks
we had in middle school
were actually defined?
BEN ORLIN: Yeah, right.
I wouldn't call them great
pieces of literature.
MAX BLUM-CAMPO: No, exactly.
BEN ORLIN: Yeah, no.
It's true.
Yeah, most the
textbooks are like that.
If you look at your pop
science shelf or something,
Mary Roach doesn't sit down
and write a book about science.
She writes a book
about human digestion,
or she writes a
book about corpses.
She has a really wacky
sense of what's exciting.
But or like Stephen
Hawking, "Brief
History of Time," that's
a pretty sweeping topic,
but it's still not attempting
to do all of physics exactly.
MAX BLUM-CAMPO: It was amazing
that you got all of math.
BEN ORLIN: Yeah, that's it.
It covers the whole thing.
You won't find anything missing.
Yeah, basically,
I mean, it's a bit
of like a magic-illusion
kind of trick
to make it feel like it's got
breadth while still having
enough depth in a few topics.
I was basically
just surprised how
it came together to feel
like a cohesive package.
Yeah, so I was very
pleased with that.
With the second
book, I had a premise
that I thought was brilliant.
It was gonna go through
calculus and connect
each concept in calculus to
something in the humanities,
to an author, or a
painter, or someone who
had played with the same ideas.
Which I thought
was really clever,
and would have been
if there were people
in the humanities
who had done that
with every idea of calculus.
It turned out I had like
three, and would have
made a pretty artificial book.
So I spent maybe
four months writing
a draft of that,
and then basically
had to start from page 1,
because there were like three
or four chapters where
it fit perfectly,
and then others where I was
just trying to shoehorn together
things that didn't fit.
So that one, that surprised me.
I'm really happy
with the draft now.
It's much more about
storytelling now.
MAX BLUM-CAMPO:
And this is the one
you showed "Change is
the Only Constant."
BEN ORLIN: Yeah, "Change
Yeah.
MAX BLUM-CAMPO: Cool.
One of the things
I wanted to jump to
is, what would your readers
who haven't met you in person
find most surprising about you.
do you think?
BEN ORLIN: There's
this weird asymmetry,
where, when I talk to
friends or family members who
read the book, they always say,
"Oh, it sounds just like you.
That's exactly what-- the
page really captures you."
And when I meet people who know
the book and then they meet me,
they're like, "You're
really not what I expected.
You're really nothing
like I was anticipating."
MAX BLUM-CAMPO: So what
were they expecting?
BEN ORLIN: I don't know.
I guess I'm more of a
writer than a performer.
So I think probably
I come across as--
on the page, I
try to come across
as a very freewheeling, circusy,
joke-making kind of person,
but I'm not.
I don't know.
I'm just kind of guy.
So I'm not as much of
a performer in person.
So I think that surprises
people a little bit.
MAX BLUM-CAMPO: Interesting.
And also for readers of
your blog and your books,
what would you tell them you are
doing when you are not writing?
BEN ORLIN: Yeah,
it's a good question.
MAX BLUM-CAMPO: Or
doing stuff like this?
BEN ORLIN: Right, exactly.
I know.
I'm just constantly--
I mean, I'm
just hanging out in here now.
This is a really nice room.
This will be my new hobby.
Yeah, it's a little funny,
really, because I went from--
I mean, during the start
of my teaching career,
teaching was my day job,
and writing and cartooning
was sort of this
passion project hobby.
And now when your
passion project hobby
becomes your professional
activity, it sort of leaves--
I'm in this weird
position now, where
I haven't taught in a
year and a half now,
and I'm really, really anxious
to get back to the classroom.
There's so much energy
there in a way that
just being in a
coffee shop typing
is a little less electric than
being around young people who
are learning new things.
So I think that's what--
yeah, that's the weird kind of
state that I'm in right now,
is having switched my
hobby and my day job.
MAX BLUM-CAMPO: So you
just spend most of the rest
of your time wishing you were--
BEN ORLIN: Yeah, pining
for the classroom.
Exactly, yeah.
You know, I like reading a lot.
Yeah, I try to read
eclectic, weird things,
because I want to write
weird, eclectic things.
MAX BLUM-CAMPO: It seems
like a good practice, then.
BEN ORLIN: Yeah.
MAX BLUM-CAMPO: Well, let's
jump to maybe some audience
and some Dory questions.
Let's start with you.
AUDIENCE: so, First
thanks so much.
That was an awesome
demonstrations
of some illustrations.
I thought the quote you
brought up from Andrew Wiles
was particularly moving and
interesting, and also relevant
for a lot of the work
that's done here too.
And so as somebody who's
taught computer science
at the high school level, I was
wondering about that building
up comfort and discomfort.
A super important
skill for math,
super important skill
for other things.
What pedagogical tactics do
you take both as a teacher
and as an author and
Illustrator to help instill
that sense into students?
BEN ORLIN: Yeah, I think
it's hard to instill
as an Illustrator-writer,
because it's
kind of an inherently
passive medium.
I'm not there in the
room with someone.
As a teacher--
I mean, you can describe
stories like that as a writer,
but it doesn't have the
same impact as actually
having the experience.
As a teacher, there's
really no substitute
for just having students
in that situation.
So coming up with problems.
The sort of ideal,
right, is to have
a problem that has a low
barrier to entry, where
you can wrap your head
around what you need to do,
where there's some kind of
intrinsic excitement to it,
where you want the
solution to this puzzle.
And then to let them
go, to not provide
answers, to not drop hints.
There's this art.
My sister is also
a math teacher,
and she's really good at the
art of nonjudgmental "Uh-huh.
Huh.
Oh, yeah."
Where some student
will propose an idea,
and you really don't wanna--
I'm always tempted to be
like "Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You're on the right track."
or "Uh, that's not
sounding good."
But to really cultivate just
the non-judgemental "OK, cool.
That's an interesting idea.
Tell me more about that."
I mean, this is always
what it comes down
to in education, is
what we spend time on
is what kids will
perceive that we value.
So if it's 9 days out of
10 is sort of technique,
and here's a technique and
now practice it, here's
a technique, now practice it.
You know, that's an
important part of math,
but if that's 9
days out of 10, kids
think that's 90% of the subject.
And so it just takes
spending classroom time on,
here is a problem, and
you're gonna work on it.
And you won't know
how to solve it,
and I'll try to give you some
models for thinking about it.
I'll try to maybe do a
simpler example on the board,
try to get a conversation going.
But really just getting
students experience
with being in that space.
MAX BLUM-CAMPO: Thank you
for the in-depth answer.
Can we show the Dory on
the screen for a second?
The first question here, I
think, is very interesting.
"How can we remove the stigma
in young children of 'math
is hard.
I shouldn't bother, and anyone
actually good at it should be
beaten up'"?
BEN ORLIN: Yeah, I mean,
I'm not convinced that they
shouldn't be beaten up.
[LAUGHTER]
I don't know.
There's a lot there.
Math is hard.
I mean, there's two
approaches to that.
One is to say, "Oh, no.
Math, yeah, it's fun.
You can get along with it."
And then to say,
"Yeah, math is hard.
That's kind of what's
cool about it."
It stretches your mind, and it's
a chance to challenge yourself
and to dive into ideas that
will change the way you think.
So I think that's one
where, as educators, you
want to own math as hard.
You don't want to dismiss that.
MAX BLUM-CAMPO: It's
OK that it's hard.
BEN ORLIN: Yeah, exactly.
Yeah, that's what's beautiful
about it, is that it's hard.
I mean, if you think
about kids, things
that kids find
intrinsically exciting,
no one's like, "Well, soccer
is too hard or too easy."
You don't think about
it in those terms.
To become a great soccer
player is really hard.
To play a little soccer
is fun and not too hard.
And it's just the activity
itself is motivating.
When it comes to that
"I shouldn't bother,"
that's what it comes down to.
Soccer and things like
guitar or musical instruments
are analogies I
think about a lot.
Because those are
things that kids
are inherently
excited about often.
Not all kids, but
music and sport
are things that we can just
dive into and be excited about.
And why isn't math one of
those things for most kids?
And I think it's pretty rare
to have a glimpse of what
doing great math looks like.
I don't know when most
kids would see that.
You can turn on the
TV and see soccer.
You can turn on the-- not
radio, because it's 2019.
But you know, turn on
whatever music app you use
and hear what great
guitar sounds like.
But where do you
look for great math?
And so I think part of what
math education has to do
is to show what does
really exciting,
engaging, interesting
mathematical problem solving
to look like?
To show the exemplar of
what we're aiming at.
MAX BLUM-CAMPO: It's a really
interesting problem to solve.
BEN ORLIN: Yeah, because
it's such a technical field
that it can be hard sometimes.
Yeah, what is great
math to someone
who knows the background
is illegible to someone who
doesn't know the background.
MAX BLUM-CAMPO: Mm-hm.
Let's take another
question from the audience.
AUDIENCE: So I guess
you can boil down
my question is, how do you
answer that question yourself?
So I remember math from high
school being rote and boring,
and well, who really cares about
algebra 2 in the first place?
BEN ORLIN: Right, yeah.
AUDIENCE: And then math from
college and grad school being,
"Oh, look.
Yeah, here's these theorems.
There's 500 ways to prove it.
Which way do you prove it?"
Do you try to bring that more
creativity and proof creation
into high school, or is that
even the tack you wanna take?
BEN ORLIN: Yeah.
Yeah, no.
It's a good question, right.
So proof in
particular, I mean, you
ask because you're
already a mathematician.
Proof is the heart of
the subject, right?
How do we move from
this Euclidean idea?
assumptions to conclusions?
The place it tends
to show up in the US,
your first encounter
often is geometry, where
you do these two column proofs.
I have not super
positive feelings
about two column proofs.
They tend to be--
it's a kind of artificial
way of setting them up.
And also, you run
into the problem
that when you're developing
any axiomatic system,
the early proofs are usually
very technical, and about
like just following out
from your definitions,
and it takes a while before
you get into the meat of it.
So you know, if you
start with Euclid,
you've got these five really
simple postulates, and then
the first few things you prove
just feel blindingly obvious
when you look at them.
And so it's not a
great playground
for proof in that sense.
It's weird to start your proof
experience by proving things--
what you learn is that
rather than proof helping
you understand things
that you didn't, proof
is when you get
confused about things
you thought you understood.
[LAUGHTER]
Which isn't really the
message we wanna send.
So how do you?
I think doing more
informal argument,
almost any mathematical
solution can
be presented as an argument,
something kind of like a proof.
And I think doing that
much earlier with students
and much more frequently
and on problems
where it's not
blindingly obvious what
you're trying to prove.
Because I think you need
to have a fair amount
of informal experience
with mathematical argument
before you can appreciate
formal mathematical proof.
MAX BLUM-CAMPO: Let's look at
another question from the Dory
here, because this looks fun.
Can you name some writing or
writers of popular mathematics
that you have been
inspired by or liked?
BEN ORLIN: Yeah, I
mean, definitely.
I try to read as much as I
can in the popular math space.
Yeah, there's been a
lot of really good--
So Simon Singh's Fermat's--
"Fermat's Enigma" was
the title in the US.
"Fermat's Last
Theorem" in the UK.
But that's one of the best
pop math books out there.
MAX BLUM-CAMPO: The US
title sounds a lot better?
BEN ORLIN: "Fermat's Enigma"?
MAX BLUM-CAMPO: Yeah.
BEN ORLIN: Yeah, it's true.
Yeah, enigmas more fun.
MAX BLUM-CAMPO: Mm-hmm.
BEN ORLIN: Yeah, right.
Theorem is not.
Yeah, that's probably
why they changed it.
MAX BLUM-CAMPO: Yeah.
BEN ORLIN: We're better at
marketing here in America.
MAX BLUM-CAMPO: Please go on.
BEN ORLIN: So and then
other recent ones, I mean,
Jordan Ellenberg has a book
called "How Not to Be Wrong,"
which is great.
Steve Strogatz has a
book called "Joy of X,"
which is a really wonderful
ABC of mathematics, starting
from counting and
building toward some more
modern mathematics.
Eugenia Chang has a
really fun book called--
this is another one with
different titles in the US
and UK, but I think "How
to Make Pi" in the US,
where she's a category
theorist and explores
some analogies between
cooking and mathematics.
Those come to mind.
Biographies of mathematicians
are often good.
Siobhan Roberts as a
biographer I really like.
She wrote a good
biography of John Conway
called, "Genius at Play."
Martin Gardner is obviously
a master of the discipline.
I mean, sort of
recreational mathematics.
I've only read bits
of what he's written.
I'm trying to
think of what else.
Yeah, I mean--
MAX BLUM-CAMPO: This is a
long list, so it's helpful.
BEN ORLIN: OK, well,
I'll stop there.
MAX BLUM-CAMPO:
But on that topic,
do you think that math is
generally getting more popular
these days?
What's going on there?
BEN ORLIN: Yeah,
there's definitely--
I feel like there's a bit of
pop math or math popularization
sort of Renaissance going on.
It probably goes along
with a renewed emphasis
on STEM communication.
That seems like
something also that--
I don't know if social media
lends itself to that, or just
the fact that visuals really
benefit science and math
communication, and
now that we've all
got pretty good screens
around us all the time,
you can have these
beautiful visuals in a way
that 30 years ago it was
actually a little harder.
I mean, TV specials could
do it, but it was harder
as a random writer to
communicate with great visuals.
Yeah, the visual is
probably part of it.
I think YouTube is actually
a really good medium
for math too.
I'm much more knowledge
about the book
side than the video
side, but there's
a lot of people doing
really good stuff.
If any of you've come
across 3Blue1Brown,
he's a master of the form.
His YouTube videos are
exceptionally good.
MAX BLUM-CAMPO: I'll
have to check that out.
BEN ORLIN: Yeah.
MAX BLUM-CAMPO: Looks like
we have another question
in the audience.
AUDIENCE: One of
the math authors
that I really admire in
math education practitioners
is Paul Lockhart, who wrote
"A Mathematician's Lament."
BEN ORLIN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And in that book and
in some other earlier studies,
he commented on how we've got
this systemic problem in math
education, where people go
through primary education,
learn that math is
horrible and they hate it,
they become math teachers,
and they teach students
that math is horrible
and they hate it.
Do you see other systemic level
ways to approach that problem
and break that cycle, other than
being a person who understands
a different perspective on
math and exemplifying that just
yourself?
BEN ORLIN: Yeah.
Yeah, I mean,
Lockhart's "Lament," it
was my first or second
year of teaching, I think,
that I read it,
and it was such a,
like the blinding light of
that essay, I loved that essay.
It opens with this
metaphor, where
he compares math education
to art education,
and has this whole extended
metaphor, where it's sort of--
I'm not gonna remember
the details of it.
But basically--
Oh, no, sorry.
Music education first, I guess.
So he compares math
education to music education,
and imagines a world in which
music education is mandatory
for everyone from K
through 12, and it
consists of transposing series
of notes into different keys,
and breaking up
things by measure
and figuring out
the time signature
from looking at sheet music.
And you never hear any music,
you just look at sheet music
and manipulate sheet
music in various ways.
Which is a really grim
metaphor for math education,
and not entirely wrong.
I think I really admire
Lockhart's idealism.
I think probably in
the last eight years
or whatever it's been since
I read that essay, I've
gotten a little more pessimistic
about the ability of just
an idealistic vision to
help transform mathematics
education, because I think in
particular one of the roles
it plays in education is as
a platform for competition.
So in particular,
AP calculus is taken
by half a million students,
quarter million students
a year.
It's a pretty common
thing to do in the US.
I think it's driven largely by
the fact that to get admission
to a competitive college, it
really helps to do AP calculus.
It's not as though calculus
teachers sat down and said,
let's make this a
competitive environment.
It's that the economy has
some zero-sum elements to it.
And for whatever reason, we
see math education and success
in math education as a
signal of competence.
And so I think part of what
drives math education being
as occasionally dry and
disappointing as it is,
is that competitive
pressure, the fact
that students want a
platform on which to compete
so they can prove themselves.
And once you have a platform
on which to compete,
well, you want very
fair, objective tests.
But once you're doing very fair,
objective, predictable stuff,
you've drained a lot
of life out of what
makes mathematics cool and fun.
I don't know.
I mean, the competitive
pressure isn't gonna go away.
So to some extent, I
don't think there's
an easy fix for that other
than to move the competition
to some other platform.
That's not a problem I feel like
I have any prescription for.
MAX BLUM-CAMPO: That
was an eloquent summary
of the problem, though.
So thank you.
Why don't we take one more
question from the audience?
AUDIENCE: So one thing I've
noticed looking at your older
drawings and your newer ones
is actually not the drawings
but the handwriting.
The handwriting in your earlier
ones is really pretty bad,
and in newer ones, I can
read what they're saying.
And I'm wondering
if you've switched
to using a font for this
or if your handwriting has
gotten better.
BEN ORLIN: No, no.
I switched to using a font.
Yeah, for the book they--
MAX BLUM-CAMPO: Oh, can we
look at the examples again?
BEN ORLIN: Sure, yeah.
MAX BLUM-CAMPO: Were the
examples present in the slides?
BEN ORLIN: It should
be there, yeah.
AUDIENCE: The more recent
ones in the slides.
Like that one, that one's OK.
But once you start
using sharpies.
BEN ORLIN: Yeah, right.
There's no text in that one.
AUDIENCE: Like that,
that's pretty hard to read.
BEN ORLIN: Yeah, that
is tough to read.
And then you're right,
also pretty tough to read.
And then if you go to the
current ones, still not great.
It was actually for the--
that's still handwriting.
Yeah, so this is the font now.
MAX BLUM-CAMPO: Ah.
AUDIENCE: I was thinking
maybe, Ben, put some work
into figuring this out.
A different kind.
BEN ORLIN: Absolutely.
MAX BLUM-CAMPO: You
didn't make this font?
BEN ORLIN: It was a
very cool experience.
My publisher told
me, actually, they
needed a font for the book.
Because you can't-- the things I
learned about publishing that I
probably should have
known in advance,
you can't just submit
handwritten scrawl.
They're like, "We need
to copy edit this.
We might translate it.
We need to provide
files to people.
We can't just take your scrawl.
That's not gonna work."
So what they did
is, they sent me
to a man named [? Chenk, ?]
who lives in the Twin Cities.
He must have a last name, but
I know him only as [? Chenk. ?]
And he had me draw, like write
the alphabet a couple of times,
and write some other characters.
He threw in some
Greek letters for me.
I got to write Greek letters.
And that's if I
can figure out how
to make that happen
in my word processor.
And he turned it
into this lovely font
that looks like my
handwriting, but is way better.
MAX BLUM-CAMPO:
That's really cool.
How much does
[? Chenk ?] charge?
Is it something I
can do for myself?
BEN ORLIN: Yeah. yeah,
you could if you wanted.
Yeah, I mean, it's not
cheap, but it's affordable.
MAX BLUM-CAMPO: All
right, [? Chenk. ?]
So I have one last
question, which is, is there
anything in particular
that you think
Googlers should learn
from your writing
or maybe from your experiences?
BEN ORLIN: Yeah.
No, that's a good question.
I mean, I probably have a
lot more to learn from--
I mean, I always enjoy
talking to Googlers
and hearing how
things work here.
I mean, the thing I've
been doing, especially
with these two books,
is figuring out ways
to write about a very
technical subject in very
non-technical ways.
MAX BLUM-CAMPO: Mm-hmm.
BEN ORLIN: And the basic
reason being that, technicality
is often a barrier to entry.
You know, people run into the
dense symbolism of mathematics,
and people just bounce
off and go away.
And so yeah, thinking
about how to communicate
about complex technical
things in clear and easily
transmitted ways, I mean, that's
the role of any kind of math
or science popularizer, I guess.
But I think the tools that math
and science popularizers come
up with might be useful
in an environment
where you guys all have
the technical background,
but also there's
still-- even for someone
with the technical
background-- it's slower
to read a technical
document than to read
a non-technical summary.
MAX BLUM-CAMPO: Like
what you've done.
BEN ORLIN: Yeah.
MAX BLUM-CAMPO: Well, thank
you so much for taking the time
to come here and talk to us.
BEN ORLIN: Yeah, no.
Thank you.
It's been really fun.
MAX BLUM-CAMPO: About
your writing experience
and your teaching experience.
And I think it's been really
enlightening for all of us,
so yeah, thank you very much.
BEN ORLIN: All right, thanks.
[APPLAUSE]